One way of cheating on associativity
is called way prediction.
We start with a set-associative
cache which has a low miss rate but
would have a slow hit time.
Now what we do, we guess which line
in the set is the most likely to hit.
So what we do is we use the index
bits to determine which set should we
be looking at and now instead of reading
out all the tags in that line and
checking which one hits, we guess
which one is the likely to hit and
just check that one.
So this gives us the access
time similar to a direct-mapped
cache if we guessed right.
If we are wrong,
then we got no hit on the line we tried.
But the set has other lines, so
we try a normal set-associative check,
which will have a higher hit time.
So the idea is that, overall, our miss
rate is that of a set-associative cache.
We either find it this way or this way.
So the miss rate will be
similar to a set-associative
cache because even if we didn't find
it in a kind of direct-mapped way,
we will find it this way.
But the hit time,
if our guesses are mostly right,
is mostly that of a direct-mapped cache.
So we have combined the low miss
rate of a set-associative cache with
most of the time getting the hit time of
a direct-mapped cache and sometimes only
having to suffer the longer hit time
of a normal set-associative cache.